people who have philosophical concerns
about going to the courts don't have
kids and failing schools you know it's
kind of a think tank argument it's not
the argument that that is going to ever
resonate with a mother who has a child
who's in a failing school I'm Katherine
Maggie award with reason TV and I'm here
today with Campbell Brown former CNN
host and now a education reformer thanks
for joining me good to be here so tell
me about why you decided to make the
transition from the glamorous world of
television to the really sexy world of
education reform I became a mother I
mean that's really the easy answer and
having covered politics for a long time
as a reporter and policy issues suddenly
they become very personal and to me
education as I started to think about it
for my kids what I saw in New York was
this extreme inequality my kids were
gonna get a certain kind of education
because I had had this great career on
TV and I had the resources to give them
whatever you know I wanted I had choice
and to have educational choice exist
only for people with money in our
society is crazy and wrong to me and
it's it's very much not a political
issue to me but a moral issue so talk
about the losses there was the vegara
lawsuit which was sort of a landmark
ruling and then you through the
partnership for educational justice and
your work have another lawsuit now
pending so can you just kind of describe
the landscape sure what happened in
California was really quite
extraordinary these families brought a
case challenging teacher tenure laws
lastin first-out seniority rules that
basically mean if there ever have to be
layoffs that the sole factor taken into
account is seniority and also dismissal
protections that make it almost
impossible to remove an abusive or
grossly ineffective teacher they won in
California we were watching I work with
a lot of parent groups in New York and
when we saw the ruling and the judge in
how he wrote his his decision was really
quite extraordinary
in saying that the evidence presented of
how these children were being a deny the
quality education
it shocks the conscience and his words
gave these parents in New York who are
I'm supporting nine families hope that
that a judge in New York might
understand these arguments and find the
same thing so they have brought a case a
very similar to the Vergara case in New
York challenging the same laws teacher
tenure lastin first-out seniority and
dismissal laws on constitutional grounds
on behalf of their kids and for people
who don't follow this issue as closely
why is it that this judge among other
people see the teacher tenure rules as
they are now sort of lead us to create
this straight line to very low quality
education can you kind of connect those
- sure so it's the way that these laws
all work together I think that prevents
us from getting the most effective
teachers in front of the most kids
possible teacher tenure in New York is
given up to three years and in many
cases I think you know if you look at
surveys of teachers they agree that the
awarding of tenure isn't really
performance-based it's perfunctory it's
automatic and it becomes automatic
lifetime employment once the teacher has
tenure because of the dismissal law and
the way it works with tenure it because
it can become almost impossible to
remove that teacher if they are grossly
ineffective or as I said before it even
if they are abusive talked a little bit
about the decision to go to the courts
to do this I mean there is certainly a
spotty history of courts dictating how
schools are run or trying to reshape
education that doesn't always work
do you fear as I think some and
reformers do that by by sort of asking
the courts to do this in a top-down way
you're making a Faustian bargain you
know I think the people who who have
concern you know philosophical concerns
about going to the courts don't have
kids and failing schools you know it's
kind of a think-tank argument it's not
the argument that that it's going to
ever resonate with a mother who has a
child who's in a failing school know now
look if you win this case basically what
the judge is going to say as happened in
California in cases on appeal but
presumably you will need to go through a
legislative process to
rewrite the laws if they are declared
unconstitutional so I think you also
have to have a parallel legislative
strategy for what a good tenure law
looks like what a better dismissal law
looks like and you have to make the case
publicly to win public opinion so that
you can actually get a legislature to
move and so in my mind
win or lose what these cases are doing
is prompting a big public debate in a
way that we haven't had before so for
everyone who sort of sees you talking
about this and says like she's right you
know I'm gonna call my legislator you've
had a fair amount of people who have
seen you talking about this and they've
said I'm gonna go after her personally
because I disagree with her can you kind
of describe what the reaction has been
to your foray into this area yeah well
no look the the teachers unions are very
powerful you know there has been a
pretty aggressive campaign to try to
discredit the messengers whether it's me
or anybody else who's tried to speak up
about this I don't particularly care
because you know sticks and stones
it just better they come after me than a
mother who you know has a kid in that
school who's having to fight this fight
every single day in a much more personal
way than I am thank you very much for
taking the time to talk with us today
you're welcome
you